avec le confinement de nombreux secteurs
d'activité sont touchés de plein fouet
et ont peur pour leur avenir
c'est le cas de nombreux restaurateurs
impact est violemment d'un point de vue
économique depuis la fermeture
obligatoire au public de tous les
établissements et dont le chef de l'état
a annoncé hier le prolongement pour un
mois supplémentaire minimum une
situation qui met particulièrement en
colère le cuisinier philippe etchebest
qui a décidé de s'exprimer publiquement
sur le sujet pour lui il faut que ça
cesse la situation est catastrophique
dans nos métiers nous représentons un
million d'emplois dans l'hôtellerie
restauration
un million d'emplois vous entendez ce
qui est énorme
au mois de mars 30% des restaurateurs
n'ont pas pu payer leurs salariés et au
moins d'avril y en aura plus on estime à
peu près à 70 % des restaurateurs qui ne
pourront pas payer leurs salariés pour
lui la situation est alarmante et pour
beaucoup ce confinement signe le coup de
grâce
on est en plein cauchemar je pense à
tous ces restaurateurs que gvt et était
déjà en difficulté
il avait peut-être une chance de s'en
sortir après mon intervention
mais là je crois que c'est
définitivement mort alors comprenez vous
le coup de gueule de philippe etchebest
sur le maintien de la fermeture de
restaurants alors est ce que vous
comprenez le coup de gueule de philippe
etchebest c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ont parlé ça
intéresse énormément de personnes ça
touche beaucoup beaucoup de monde
puisque bien sûr là les restos il ya les
personnes qui travaillent dedans
raymond est ce que tu comprends le coup
de gueule de philippe etchebest toi bah
moi je suis obligé de comprendre son
coup de gueule parce que moi ça fait 27
ans que je que je livre les restaurants
les hôtels et compagnie et comme il a
dit c'est 900 mille emplois 900 milles
en coupé en deux sens mais l'entreprise
et ses 85 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
et tous les gens qui bossent à côté de
la restauration parce que ça fait beau
c'est aussi beaucoup de gens les hôtels
donc les restaurateurs on s'est toujours
relevé de quoi que ce soit des grèves
des gilets jaunes des attentats on s'est
toujours relevé à partir du moment où
qu'on pouvait avoir l'occasion d'être
ouvert mais comme l'a dit philippe
esteva si je suis d'accord avec lui
c'est les belges sncb
c'est un drame c'est un drame parce
qu'il ya des leçons à 84%
il faut penser par soi qu'il ya même des
couples qui bosse dans la restauration
et pour ces gens là c'est trente deux
ans au moins et après la double lame et
je finis avec sa [ __ ] fait là
le land c'est que on est conscient nous
dans la restauration que même quand on
va aller ouvrir la première chose que
les gens vont serre ils vont pas sauter
dans un restaurant non boîte de nuit et
dans un restaurant avec un masque il
sait comment pour manger donc on alors
on a là vraiment vraiment il ya plein de
gens qui sont pas d'accord avec toi sur
les réseaux qu'ils disent je vous le dis
ce les français sont trop indisciplinés
si on ouvre bars et restaurants ça
serait la pagaille philippe etchebest tu
penses pas à la santé pour le coup les
restaurants attendront pour l'heure la
santé de tous de tout le monde primes
non si les cantines scolaires ou
d'entreprises réouvre pourquoi pas les
restos il ya quelqu'un qui est d'accord
voilà j'ai essayé vrai dire il sert il
cyril gely qu'il se faire ouvrir les
restaurants j'ai dit que c'était une
catastrophe
oui mais oui là n'ont donc donc tu
comprends pas ce coup de gueule parce
que lui dit qu'il faut rouvrir les
restaurants donc c'est pas entendu ce
qu'il a dit qu'il fallait ouvrir 6 6 et
6 lits alors on aura thierry marx qui va
nous donner son avis dans un instant et
rennes mathieu delormeau banon va ça va
énerver son coup de gueule c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi pas pour [ __ ]
un peu la merde parce que si on va là
dessus oui il dit qu'il est réputé
restaurant ray ou bas merci beaucoup
philippe mais dans ces cas là pardon moi
j'ai deux amis qui ont une boîte de nuit
et qu'ils vont mettre la clé sous la
porte dans les boîtes de nuit vont
crever les salles de sport vont crever
les bars vont crever je peux te faire
une liste de sociétés qui ne passeront
pas l'été donc il est gentil philippe
etchebest nous parle des restaurants
parce qu'il est une émission sur m6
enfin si tu veux il y aura une boîte de
nuit le réparer des mecs de boîte de
nuit de rester mais je vous dis c'est
bien ce que je dis donc il ya un moment
donné c'est très gentil de fait la
profession
enfin je peux te citer dix professions
qui vont crever cet été donc toi alors
qu'ils qui vient foot paga les feux ya
greg ya grecque qui nous dit était pmp
en étant serveur c'est une vraie
catastrophe et on comprend les femmes
dans les po les restaurateurs bien sûr
qu'on pense très très fort à eux et eux
n'ont perturbé depuis la fac ou diode
pour dire que les restaurants devrait
réouvrir alors j'envie germé après
j'aimerais qu'on écoute thierry marx et
bien sûr rené malleville mais thierry il
va nous donner son avis de professionnel
ça c'est important oui jean michel ouais
moi je suis et je comprends pas
l'intervention de philippe etchebest je
suis d'accord c'est un drame mais il n'y
a pas de commerce qui peuvent rouvrir ce
qu'on peut faire un système genre de
service à la porte
objet à côté de chez moi pour des
parisiens pour des débats port est
ou alors les gens entre un parent dans
le magasin mais le principe de restant
s'est collé plusieurs confinés dans un
espace restreint avec en échange des
choses et star c'est très dangereux donc
en profiter
celle où les restaurateurs pour les y
autoriser des rires les restaurateurs a
cédé ferveur moi je pense aux serveurs
tout ça et tout cas dans les restaurants
tous les gens qui sont cuisine aussi il
ya des gens qui lisent la santé beaucoup
plus importante que l'économie
tout à fait d'accord les restaurants et
les commerces c'est eux qui font
l'économie
donc il faut qu'ils réouvre y ait
quelqu'un qui dit est chaud baisse n'a
pas écouté le discours il y aura des
aides des suppressions de jazz secteur
qui n'auront pas le droit de rouvrir en
plus qu'ils gueulent contre le virus pas
le président il préfère qu'on rouvre
tout et que les personnes à risque crève
philippe etchebest tu nous saoules non
ce n'est pas un plaisir aux et raymond
le matin désolé mais tout le monde est
concerné ne soyez pas égoïste aller
thierry marx est avec nous thierry marx
chef cuisinier étoilé parisien que
j'adore thierry qui est un chef
exceptionnel et qu'un garçon d'une
humidité incroyable qui pratique
également les arts martiaux et je sais
qui c'est vrai que c'est un type
formidable qui rit kiri merci d'être là
thiery merci merci de m'accueillir dont
je comprends le le côté anxiogène de ce
qui se passe dans la fermeture des
restaurants chenaux mail je vis cette
situation de façon pénible à savoir
qu'en france quand même il ya une
protection qui a été mise sur leur toit
le travail partiel
salem pas si mal et savoir que c'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est un virus donc il ya
certes de barrières sanitaires à mettre
en place et je pense que les syndicats
professionnels qui aujourd'hui
travaillent sur quelle façon pour
réouvrir quelle va être la façon de
protéger ses collaborateurs et quelle
façon on va pouvoir protéger aussi nos
clients donc un ensemble de choses
c'est une méthode raisonnée tactique
dirait on prend les problèmes un par un
et on essaie de les résoudre pour la
restauration
effectivement qui dit chef dix chefs
bien sûr et ça c'est là la magie de
notre métier est dit aussi chef
d'entreprise et je comprends l'anxiété
mais sur bien évidemment nous on en a
parlé du virus parce qu'on a des
entreprises qui sont aussi en acier
depuis le mois de janvier
très honnêtement je faisais comme tout
le monde un peu la politique de
l'autruche n'est ce pas chez nous ça
n'arrivera pas on avait déjà des
informations de ce qui se passait en
chine
et aujourd'hui on voit toute la
mécanique qui a été remise en place pour
réouvrir des restaurants c'est
extrêmement compliqué et puis des
nouveaux business qui vont se mettre en
place et qui se mettent déjà en place
sur la vente à emporter et je crois que
bien sûr que c'est pénible
ces situations mais il va y avoir des
opportunités qui vont se créer pour
essayer de faire du chiffre d'affaires
autrement en attendant que l'économie
reparte et moi je ne la vois pas
repartir très sérieusement avant le mois
de septembre octobre et je surprends
vous prêtez de mes confrères
vraiment je la comprends pas ce jeu là
lui et en termes de trésorerie
aujourd'hui même s'il ya des prêts aidés
même s'il ya tant de choses qui sont
faites en france et sachez bien que
c'est pas le cas à l'étranger où on
licencie des personnes du jour au
lendemain
dont en france on est quand même un peu
protégés effectivement c'est le principe
de précaution pour protéger la santé
rené malleville oui alors là moi je suis
assez un peu circonspecte parce que en
interne il reste à en ouvrir mais moi je
te prends le cas de ma deuxième fille
j'avais une équipe de départ l'hôtel est
cuisinière au collège andré malraux à
chabbert martel élevé et le 11 mai
depuis bien elle reprend le travail et
les cuisinières d'un sur restant ce
collège il ya huit chalets lèvres et
donne le 11 mai martyrs faire la cuisine
avec c'est bien sûr je comprends tout à
fait ce que tu dit rooney parce qu'il ya
plein de gens sur twitter qui disent
exactement la même chose que toi
alors ça on va en parler dans un instant
parce qu'on va parler des écoles
justement et de tout ça et de toute
personnelle qui va travailler dans les
écoles puisqu'elles vont réouvrir le 11
mai ça aussi c'est un gros problème et
tu fais bien de le relever rooney parce
qu'on va en parler dans un instant mais
sur les restaurants c'est vrai que les
gens je vous dis on va on va lancer le
sondage mais a priori ce sont un peu
comme thierry marx où ils disent la
santé avant tout et on peut pas inscrire
les restaurants parce que voilà c'est
c'est eh voilà on aimerait bien sûr que
l'économie reparte c'est ce que disent
les gens mais forcément il faut penser
avant tout à la santé franck tapiro qui
est avec nous des fraudes
merci d'être là mon franck qu'est ce
t'en penses quoi de coups de gueule de
philippe etchebest donc de comprendre tu
sais c'est normal on annonça des
continents il ya une date qui est prévu
mais encore une fois c'est un objectif
c'est pas une date fixe et on sait que
cela serve as trop partiel façon
progressive et bien entendu ça peut pas
toucher tous les secteurs
bien entendu on sait que le secteur de
la restauration est pas que celui-ci du
tourisme en général
des hôtels les restaurants les cafés
mais il souffre énormément et est donc
évidemment que ça redémarre pas ce qu'on
connaît leurs difficultés
maintenant c'est vrai que même si ça
n'attire plus tard entre temps il ya des
mesures d'exception
à situation exceptionnelle mesure
d'exception un accompagnement économique
mais ça a été organisé
bruno le maire qui lui-même aussi talla
est elle valable donc je pense quand
même que même si c'est bon je peux
comprendre la déception c'est plutôt la
déception et la frustration
heureusement on est comme protégé il
était vraiment dans l'affairé au maximum
à accompagner toute cette tout ce
secteur qui est ont décidé en tout cas
moi je pour moi je pars d'un principe
vous dire les restaurateurs moi je pense
beaucoup beaucoup peu tous les métiers
de la restauration parce que je pense ça
va être très très difficile pour après
parce que est ce que vous imaginez une
fois qu'on va dire que ça va être des
confiné croyez vraiment que les gens ils
vont aller faire la queue pour aller au
restaurant ils vont aller manger à côté
de quelqu'un qui connaisse pas il veut
dans des restaurants ils vont avoir peur
mine de rien d'aller dans des
restaurants d'être corrigés dans un
restaurant d'aller là bas c'est mine de
rien les uns à côté des autres vous
allez pas manger avec un masque c'est
impossible donc forcément je pense que
les restaurations avant que ça redonne à
un vrai que ça redémarre qu'au-delà des
tirs et marque
je pense qu'avec septembre octobre voire
peut-être plus et c'est vrai qu'il va
falloir vraiment les idées parce que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'emplois et forcément il va falloir
faire quelque chose pour il ya 53 % des
gens qui sont d'accord avec le coup de
gueule de philippe etchebest mais juste
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
nous disent je sais pas pourquoi on va
pouvoir aller en classe dont on va
mettre des élèves 25 élèves dans vingt
mètres carrés et quelle est la
différence avec 25 clients dont 100
mètres carrés dans un restaurant alors
ça tout le monde nous pose la question